there's some people who have never heard
of the island of Samoa ever I would give
up personally and I would say do you
have you heard of Hawaii it's near there
in reality it's not near there at all
many people think were just passive
people they often mistake it with being
lazy lazy Hawaiians being lazy and then
when I tell them oh I'm from Guam you're
from Guam where's Guam I would tell
people that I'm Tung and they would be
like so is that like Hawaiian is that
like the hula dancers in the luaus and
oftentimes I would just have to settle
and say that that's close enough I think
when you say Pacific Islanders the first
thing that comes to most people's minds
our big sports stars or big athletes
we're actually on pigeon-holed into the
athletic category but I was never one to
be really into sports
I've never played sports and when I tell
them that they insist that I should play
sports because that's going to be a
waste of height and it's in my genes
I've been called flyin Hawaiian or I'll
be asked do the haka which is not really
um a Samoan thing they insist they know
more about myself than I actually do
know about myself Hawaii was illegally
annexed the United States a bunch of
American businessmen wanted to have
access to the land and they got the
support of the US Navy and they
basically told the Queen you can let us
have rights to your land or we can fire
on you and destroy you we are citizens
of the United States although people
back on islands don't get to vote for
president we are something with a small
group of citizens in the United States
that don't actually have presidential
voting rights and I distinctly remember
asking my professor it was the first day
of school did the syllabus and it was
the upper division course like the last
port of your Asian American Studies
class I asked him are we ever going to
learn about Pacific Islanders and he's
like well unfortunately there isn't a
professor who can talk about Pacific
Islanders we won't be able to highlight
that and I was just really upset and I
remember just feeling like I myself
teach myself if I have to I'm a look at
schools that have Pacific Islander
studies and teach myself about myself
and that's like the one hardest thing I
had to do growing up seeing things on TV
Hawaiians
weren't really portrayed in such a
positive way and then when they think of
Islanders they always think of like hula
dancers or lilo and stitch type
characters tikis and hula dancing the
wrong kind of hula dancing it's tough
growing up as a Pacific Islander and
maybe feeling that you don't fit into
those things that are presented in
mainstream media the rules I would go
out for would be like accented English
foreign exchange student hard yuku girl
or like a prostitute
what are so strong values within your
cultures oh yes family is number one we
always look after one another sometimes
I feel like nothing else matters in the
world all that matters is if we have
each other all my cousins we all
consider each other brothers and sisters
and even people call us like hey that's
your cousin Donna that's my brother we
always want to feed everybody a lot of
humility is rooted in being Pacific
Islander in general stories are so
important and we would hear from my
grandparents and their generation all
the stories from when they were growing
up and especially for people from the
Mariana Islands stories typically
involve war and the impact that World
War two had on the islands and on our
grandparents generation as they were
growing up my grandmother when she was
16 years old was put into a camp she
found out that she was going to be
killed and she fled with her siblings
all down to age two into a cave where
she lived for 18 months she collected
coconuts for water and she told us how
you could make clothing out of coconuts
how you could literally survive off of
the coconut I actually myself took like
a touristy like canoe paddling trip with
my dad or like battle canoe for a couple
hours with this guy who was a guy he was
saying you know the native population
was wiped out was just decimated by
Captain Cook and like British and
American sailors because Hawaiians were
not immune to those diseases because of
that and because of our dwindling
numbers like the Hawaiian race is going
to disappear I just felt such sadness
and loss that like our people in our
culture will disappear we got it's
making me emotional to step thinking
about it um
[Music]
it's very sad the very sad would you
know that your people are going to fade
into time and history take into account
we are at real people or tangible we're
not your Island destination for a
getaway we have a culture that is
different from many others around the
world and we have kind of our unique
place in the middle of the Pacific
Hawaii is really special the land is
alive it is old it's really powerful
it's very special knowing that you have
a connection to that I don't know ask
don't just assume so more people are
here we're a small group but we are
absolutely here especially with or
Pacific Islander people it's okay to
struggle no struggle especially as some
minorities within a minority you just
have to push through
[Music]
you
Wow